Harvard Under Fire because their
president Claudine gay
uh defended calls for genocide against
the Jews as as requiring a little bit of
context you know I'm not quite sure if
it's harassment and also then she was
caught plagiarizing I guess basically
everything she's ever written including
thank you notes for Christmas gifts you
know she's just PL plagiarized
everything and uh now we found out that
the Harvard
president uh once created a quote task
force on visual culture and signage to
make white men less visible at Harvard
we found this out thanks to Chris
rufo who is on a Jihad against claudian
gay and might might still end up getting
her fired he pointed out that after the
George Floyd riots during the George
Floyd riots uh gay commissioned this
task force that released a series of
recommendations for engaging with the
quote historical Reckoning with racial
Injustice and the recommendations
included a mandate to change quote
spaces whose visual culture is dominated
by homogeneous portraiture of white men
homogeneous you know all those white
guys look the same you know you know how
all those black guys look the same oh
hold on you're not allowed to say that
oh man that' be you'd be totally
canceled if you said that but now those
white guys they're all just they're all
just stupid evil white guys I hate them
they're the worst aren't they I hate
those white guys well anyway that's what
the Harvard president thinks she said we
need to get rid of all these pictures of
white men she said that administrators
needed to refresh the walls of annenburg
hall because it quote prominently
displayed a series of 23 portraits none
of which depict women and all but three
of which depict white men and we hate
these white men it doesn't say who the
white men are so they usually leave out
who the white men are because they're
some of the most accomplished people
ever in history that's why they have
their portraits on the wall but but they
don't want to get into that they just
say we hate Whitey we hate the white
guys get rid of them we need to refresh
things because of these stale disgusting
awful white men this woman is awful this
woman
Claudine gay this president of Harvard
is just cartoonishly awful she goes
before Congress first of all there's the
Pome on Israel probably the largest Pome
ever you know certainly in recent
history and uh the the Hamas runs in
totally uh unexpected attack and her
first response is silence her first
response is while the Harvard students
are are defending Hamas silence then
because of that she and the the pen upen
president get dragged before Congress
and she and the pen lady both say that
well you know calls for genocide against
the Jews it doesn't necessarily
constitute harassment you know when you
really think about it and this and that
and this and that so the pen lady gets
fired because she's white and we hate
white people remember white people are
evil they're terrible so she gets fired
instantly Claudine G is not white she
also hates white people apparently she
wants to refresh Society by getting rid
of the white people so she gets to stay
in office because if you fire her she
would be uh you would be racist
rather but then we found on top of that
thanks to Chris rufo and Aon sarum the
journalist that this woman has
plagiarized everything from her doctoral
dissertation in school to I think she
has a total of 11 academic
Publications actual Scholars have 11
academic Publications before they leave
graduate school okay but Claudine gay
who is manifestly not an actual scholar
has 11 total in her entire career and
she plagiarized those including the
acknowledgments in her academic
Publications such as they are so then
they get her on that but they still
don't want to fire her because it'd be
racist to fire her go fire another Karen
at another IB League school but you
can't fire Claudine gay and now we find
out that she undertook an active
campaign to get rid of the white guys on
campus is it any Wonder then the numbers
are in numbers don't lie that Harvard's
early admission applications have
dropped to a 4year low Harvard's early
admission apps are down
177% right now go to higher bond.com if
you are single you've probably seen or
heard about all the insane dating apps
out there but what if I told you there
was a dating app that actually cared
about your morals your biblical values
higher bond is the new Christian dating
app built to be safer less stressful and
more crisis centered higher bond is
completely different than anything else
out there there's no addictive swiping
the focus is truly on quality over
quantity it is designed to form lasting
marriages higher bond is veteran owned
by a husband and wife looking to change
the way Christian singles meet online
it's no secret that left-wing media and
big Tech are against companies like
higher bond in fact one of the major
tech companies is preventing higher bond
from running ads on their platform their
ad team took a screenshot of higher
Bond's website highlighted the parts
that said Christian in yellow and said
this is why we're not going to run your
ads it it's almost unbelievable except
we see these kinds of things so often
now our society our country need what
higher bond is providing if you're
single you got to check out higher
bond.com sign up before New Year's Eve
and get three months of highbond Premium
absolutely free H bond.com today right
now head on over to Pac shield.com promo
code nolles whether you are a parent a
frequent traveler or simply an
individual seeking enhanced personal
safety you need to check out pack Shield
Pack Shield is a ballistic insert that
fits into backpacks messenger bags and
briefcases the insert meets the National
Institute of justice and 3A standards to
stop a 44 magnum pack Shield comes in a
variety of sizes and colors plus it
weighs less than most textbooks and
laptops so it can be easily transferred
from bag to bag I have some pack Shields
great thing about them is no one can
tell I have it on my person they are
extreme extremely lightweight
inconspicuous I love knowing that I and
you and anyone who gets it can be
protected with pack Shield it is easier
to keep your head down I know it it's
easier to not think about potential
threats that you could encounter in
public life you got to think about those
things you got to be prepared pack
Shield gives me peace of mind pack
Shield should never be used for any
reason other than personal defense so
pack some protection and some peace of
mind with Pac Shield check them out for
yourself at Pac shield.com promo codee
nles KW for 20% off that is AK
shield.com promo code nolles K Wes for
20% off today Harvard having real-time
recruiting students it's weird isn't it
Harvard's supposed to be one of if not
the most prestigious universities in the
country 4E low 177% down on early
admissions what's that about it can't be
about the plagiarism Scandal actually
because the deadline for early action
was November 1st and the plagiarism
Scandal didn't break until a couple
weeks ago it can't be even the
Congressional testimony the
Congressional testimony was
after the
deadline what it was though I think was
was related to the October 7th pgr
because after that attack you had all of
the Harvard groups something like two
dozen Harvard student groups voicing
support for the Palestine Liberation
movement and for Hamas and that just
doesn't look good it created a real
wedge in the Democrat Party The Wedge
being that Elite Democrats older
Democrats support Israel younger
Democrats activist Democrats support
Palestine
Liberation there's not a lot of room for
reconciliation there that is a proper
wedge
and th those scandals especially now
imagine if the early application
deadline were later it
the the drop would be even more
significant those scandals are actually
hurting the university 17% down is is
rough so what do we do I think we follow
Chris rufo's lead Chris rufo is a very
very
effective groman political activist
meaning he's very he's a very smart guy
he's a good Think Tank scholar he's a
good journalist but what he's really
really good at is
emulating the tactics of the political
left the radicals Antonio gromi Herbert
maruza the new left of the 1960s he can
emulate their tactics in a just way for
the principles of the right and he's
better at doing that than just about
anybody there are very few people who
come even close to Chris rufo and that's
what he's doing here he's trying to get
the Harvard president and this is the
kind of specificity that we need okay
we're not going to take then every
university in the United States the
universities are the epicenter of
leftist power the universities are where
radical leftism really came alive in the
1960s they're they provide the sin aures
for the radical leftist activists that
the downstream effects of that are
massive because all of the political
Elites go to these schools so it's it's
huge and if we could gut those
universities it would be the biggest
power grab by conservatives in
Generations but we're not going to get
rid of all of them right away we're not
going to retake those universities right
away we're not even going to going to
knock the ivvy league right
away but we might get Harvard we might
just get
Harvard if we can just persuade enough
students not to apply to Harvard and
maybe they go to Yale maybe they go to
Stanford maybe I get a kind of a kick
out of it even though Yale is extremely
leftwing too and probably wants to
resend my degree every day of the week
uh I kind of get a kick out of it
because I've rooted against Harvard for
a long time and now actually Harvard
might go down but forget about all those
schools are are extremely leftwing
Stanford Yale Princeton Cornell all of
them but if you can get the students to
go from Harvard to the peer schools you
can really weaken Harvard and then you
drive you keep pushing on the president
Scandal and you get the President to
resign in disgrace that further hits the
Harvard reputation and then you point
out to the donors that you got two dozen
Harvard student groups Marching for
Hamas that's really going to hurt the
donors that's re that's really going to
hurt the donations coming into harv and
then You' got a three-pronged attack
that seriously weakens what is the the
symbol of prestigious Elite Education in
the United States a stronghold of the
left and that's a political
win you're you're not going to take down
every woke Corporation at a time you're
going to take down budlight if that okay
that's your chance go you get one of
them you know even Target we tried to
take down Target didn't really work we
did take down budlight got to keep up
the pressure on budlight too bud light's
not the only company that's in embrace
the radical LGBT element of agenda far
from they all have but budlight did it
in in the most egregious way that they
gave us the biggest opening we took them
down we and we took a scalp a corporate
scalp that's what we got to do here with
Harvard keep it up man what a great clip
that was huh now whoa hold up ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel see you next time